so how do you stand up for yourself
without being rude now that is a very
very difficult question to answer
because a lot of people out there today
are so sensitive and they can make
assumptions very quickly but at the same
time you don't want to be treated as a
doormat every time you talk to somebody
so in this video we're gonna look a
little bit into psychology and I'm gonna
give you five tips to stand up for
yourself without being rude let's get to
it alright guys so how do you stand up
for yourself without being rude well
it's actually part of a communication
skill and the behavior is called
assertiveness and the good news is that
you can learn it the Oxford Dictionary
says assertiveness means the quality of
expressing opinions or desires in a
strong and confident way so that people
take notice now that sounds easy when
you read it but if you actually have to
implement it and do it it's not so easy
to do in real life for most people
especially if you don't want to come
across as rude or arrogant because we
know that nobody likes arrogant people
that's full of pride so let me explain
this to you in more detail of how you
can stand up for yourself without being
a jerk
be straightforward but kind now this
might be tough for people who want other
people to like them all the time even at
the cost of themselves but listen to me
very very carefully now not everybody in
the world will like you and that is okay
you need to understand that people have
different beliefs different cultures
people are different and so they won't
always agree with you or like you and
you need to number one expect it to
happen
number two accept that it is okay so be
straightforward and tell people how you
feel about something but do it in a kind
way now remember not to attack them when
you feel threatened calm yourself and
just be straightforward while you
respect the other person don't try to
beat around the bush because you will
look soft and easy to walk over and
you'll also be very hard for people to
really understand you
stand up for your beliefs while he also
respect other people's views but make
sure that your beliefs are in the right
place and then stand firm because the
way we live our lives come from our
beliefs it's always wise to be
open-minded and to listen to what other
people believe because then we also grow
and we learn but never ever let anybody
else push their beliefs on you for
example in my early twenties I became a
reborn Christian and I've met a lot of
people since then in the entertainment
industry who do not share my beliefs but
I stayed confident and true to who I am
while I also gave them the opportunity
to also share their opinions and many of
them it also became my friends over the
years I also recently started a second
channel my new channel called dlm
Christian lifestyle where I talk about
my beliefs and I got a lot of good
responses from people on this channel
but also a lot of negative ones but you
know I don't know how I will be able to
live with myself if I don't stand up for
what I believe for what I believe is
right and true we should never feel
attacked or offended when we talk to
other people about our beliefs we're all
free to make our own decisions and we
should be able to talk to each other
about it in a peaceful way now if you
give other people the opportunity to
share their own beliefs that will
usually also hear you out as well then
when you do speak to them show respect
towards them while you discuss your own
beliefs and worldviews
you gotta know when to stand your ground
and when to back down you have to learn
when to pick the right battles and at
what time because sometimes people are
just stubborn and I just bullheaded for
the sake of winning so when you realize
this that you're in this situation say
something the other person doesn't
expect at all did you have the haircut
yes and change the conversation or just
walk away gracefully or you can just
find some middle ground where you say
hey okay look I like you but we're not
gonna agree let's just agree to disagree
don't be a bully because nobody likes a
bully not even you I mean it's okay to
stand your ground to stand up for
yourself but the way you do it needs to
be done in a calm confident and a humble
way in the moment you let your emotions
run wild is the moment when you lose
yourself and you also lose the other
person's respect and then your emotional
action usually results in their reaction
before you know it you're just in a
screaming match and they just get worse
and worse and worse you can never get
your way by being too aggressive and
even if you do the other person will
hate you for it
and if you're not a bully don't waste
your time on bullies if another person
is rude or aggressive towards you a kind
word puts like cold ice water on their
hot heads and it usually stuns them for
a while because you look unaffected by
any of their harsh words for example if
somebody raises their voice and they try
to be verbally abusive I never ever
respond in the same way I smile just a
little bit to show them that I'm
unaffected and I respond kindly by
saying something like well man I like
you but you got some crazy issues so I'm
just gonna let you be a little bit just
a little bit alone and I'll see you
later
and then I usually walk away and I don't
let it affect me at all why because the
most instinctive way to respond to a
verbal abuser is to try and reason with
them because if somebody says something
like you're a loser or you're childish
your first impulse would be to defend
yourself to say no it's it's not like
that or to tell them that they are wrong
but if you do that
you also expect the verbal abuser to be
a normal person that listens to your
reasoning as well but that's just it
that's the problem the fact is is that
you cannot reason with a verbal abuser
or a bully so you need to lift yourself
above the situation by showing them that
you're unaffected by their insults and
so you show them that you're clearly on
another level now this is very important
so listen up you never ever have to
tolerate other people that treat you
poorly and you know there's actually
something that's more important than
just standing up for yourself what is it
well strong people stand up for
themselves
but stronger people stand up for others
cheers guys